from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out the biggest
differences between UK and US
McDonald's this is what a small drink
looks like in the UK this is a US small
this is what a medium drink looks like
this is a us medium and this is a
large and this is a US
large
so with our McNuggets in the UK the
default adult sizes on the menu are a
box of six a box of nine or a share box
of
20 nuggets you can get a box of four or
you can get a six piece
or 10 20 for sharing
or
ah 40 and according to the the three
McDonald's in the area they don't have
20 or 40 boxes they just do them many
GRS of 10 but this is on the
menu in the UK we got three sizes of
fries these are our small fries in the
paper bag here is the small fry these
are our medium fries in the iconic
carton here is the medium fry and then
these are our large fries and here is
the large
fry so we couldn't find an exact weight
measurement for the fries online so what
we're going to do is weigh the musle
[Music]
just out of curiosity going to bring our
trusty friend the scales back and we're
going to weigh the Big Mac and see if
there is any difference in size not sure
there will be but let's find
out
hang on hang on hang
on so while McDonald's fries might look
and taste pretty similar in the UK and
the US in the UK we only have three
ingredients which is oil salt and
potatoes the McDonald's french fries in
America have way more ingredients these
fries are made from potatoes obviously a
vegetable oil which is canola oil corn
oil soybean oil
hydrogen
hydrogenated genit hydrogenated H thank
you hydrogenated soyan oil natural beef
flavor dextrose sodium aciid phosphate
phosph phos pyrophosphate pyrophosphate
sodium acid pyrophosphate which is used
to maintain the color uh are they that
much of a different color than the ones
in the UK okay is it worth it can we get
a side by-side comparison are they that
much more bright yellow we need to put
sodium asid pyrro phosphate or whatever
it's called in it salt and I should
mention that a natural beef flavor
contains hydrolyzed wheat and hydrolyzed
milk as a starting ingredient and of
course I have no idea what that means so
the biggest calorie difference in a Big
Mac actually comes from the source in
the US they've got about 40 more
calories than we do in the UK we're not
sure if this is because there's more
sauce or because of the ingredients list
than UK it's just a little bit more
simple our sauce is made of soyon oil
Sweet Relish which is made of DIC
pickles sugar high fructus corn syrup
distilled vinegar salt corn syrup all
right two two types of corn syrup
xanthum
gum calcium chloride spice extractives
water I've heard of that egg yolks
distilled vinegar spices onion powder
salt salt propylene glycol alanate
garlic powder vegetable protein which
has hydrolyzed corn soy and wheat sugar
Cal color turmeric extractives of
paprika and of course
soy lechin leapin
leaan I don't know which one it is so if
you are trying to eat healthily at
McDonald's it might actually be the
drinks that you have to look out
[Music]
for that's nothing
guys our chocolate shake 840 calories
that's as many calories as two
cheeseburgers and one hamburger so what
does that all mean if you were to walk
into a UK McDonald's and Order yourself
a large Big Mac meal with a milkshake it
would be around 1,400 calories and if
you were to get the large big Mach meal
with the chocolate shake in America the
total here is
1,870 calories so that's 1,870 calories
the daily calorie allowance for an
American dude is
2500 okay so you have 630 left uh one
McNugget is 55 calories right so you
could also have uh 11 more nuggets and
uh there you go that's all you need for
the
day here's everything you can only get
at a UK McDonald's so here we got the
veggie deluxe burger which is a veggie
burger that served with some mayo and
some
lettuce here we've got a chicken Legend
which is a chicken burger again served
with mayo and lettu chicken Legend I I
don't even know what that is not going
to catch on that can stay in the UK we
have a range of wraps that you can get
in the UK we have a wrap of the day here
we've got the fita crisp which is some
chicken along with some veg and some
spicy fita sauce here we've got some
Veggie Dippers these were actually
introduced as part of veganer in 2020 in
the UK but they've stuck on the menu so
these are vegan Society approved and the
sort of like a fried bean Patty sort of
thing like pick a more unappetizing
thing to get at McDonald's that differs
and then finally we've got some
mozzarella Dippers which are just kind
of mozzarella sticks
really well sucks to be in the UK cuz
everything you see right here is USA
only
baby USA
only so I'm going to talk about the
coffee drinks fast here in the US we
have all the same coffee drinks they do
in the UK but every coffee drink has an
iced version and also a caramel Andor
French vanilla Andor mocha version
depending on what you're getting so we
in the US of course have more variety
shamrock shake the Shamrock Shake is
like it's like vanilla and mint shake
strawberry sunde this is recently been
discontinued in the UK sorry guys still
got in the US my favorite as a kid
caramel sundae fruit and yogurt parfait
maybe it's healthy I have no idea
probably not those were the cold items I
want to get out of the way as they
slowly melt under these lights got a lot
more to go through Harry bear with me
here buddy buttermilk crispy chicken
sandwich yo I think this was introduced
when the chicken sandwich Wars are
really heating up when Chick-fil-A
started taken over let's see what's
under the
hood look at that look at this
yeah quar pound of with cheese deluxe
this is your fancy quar pound of with
cheese this is uh for a Sunday dinner
when you have company over ah there's so
much sausage breakfast burrito even
after it's for a while it's like still
like glowing
yellow now these are the
buttermilk crispy chicken tenders these
smell amazing I want to bite in these so
bad just take a big bite I want to talk
about sauces real quick okay I'm at
McDonald's and I go give me one of
everything I've heard from the I've
heard from Harry and the team over at
the UK that some of these I don't have
including sweet and sour honey mustard
what else don't you guys have I don't
think you guys have Ranch either or
Buffalo I got to say though the sauces
are everything we got a couple of sauces
that are kind of unique to the UK as
well we got a sweet Curry dipping sauce
and then we've also got a salsa dip as
well which I didn't know existed until
today oh yes donuts sticks these
doughnut sticks also come with a
chocolate dipping sauce another thing
I'm certain they don't have in the UK
yeah breakfast is
served look at this oh yeah who's ready
to start the day it's McGriddle
[Applause]
talk so for those of you in the UK who
don't know what a MCG griddle is uh the
United States McDonald's had this genius
idea what if we took breakfast
sandwiches replaced the buns and made
them pancakes and somehow injected some
sort of syrup flavor into the pancakes
and the McGriddle was born and I have to
say they're fantastic this one right
here the bacon egg and cheese
McGriddle this is the uh
sausage yeah hi
heyy this is the sausage EG and cheese
McGriddle American food engineering at
its finest look at
that in the UK you guys call biscuits
cookies here no so in the
UK biscuits are cookies or what we call
cookies in the US uh biscuits or what we
call uh I don't know what else you can
call them like you bake them and they're
from the south and they're dry and I
don't know what they are much like the
McGriddles we have a version of every
breakfast sandwich that instead of the
regular bun bread it's Biscuits not the
cookie biscuits like you guys have um
these biscuits Joe you were so close on
the whole cookie biscuit thing what you
guys call biscuits we would actually
kind of call scon or scones depending on
where you're from and the thought of
putting breakfast food in between them
is kind of weird they're usually
reserved for cream and jam for an
afternoon
last and in my opinion least is this
thing the southwest grilled chicken
salad
yeah can I can I I eat now yeah
yeah I don't care how many calories it's
just really
good
mhm from calorie count to portion sizes
we want to find out all the differences
between McDonald's in India and the US
this is food
Wars drinks in McDonald's India come in
three sizes regular medium and large
drinks of the McDonald's in the US four
sizes extra small small medium and
large time to keep them
honest lost a couple drops 26 27 FL
o
h fries in India come in three sizes
regular medium and large in America our
fries come in four sizes I think we have
a small kids or kids small I can't tell
the difference either medium and large
the medium and large come in these
really cool new packaging where you can
just open it up like that and it's nice
and easy to share it's a little plate
good job McDonald's very Innovative but
now it's time to measure and see how
much we're really getting first things
first the
large 175 G obviously it's different or
Scoops or whatever yeah let's go here
this one almost exactly 100 G this
one 80 g fry math hang
on this is like yep there you go 20
that's 20 G difference right there so
you tell me internet is the kids in the
small different sizes I don't think they
are food Wars is on it they're on it
baby what about McNuggets here in India
you can order them in three sizes six
pieces nine pieces and 20 pieces they
gave it to us in two boxes of 10 each oh
is that it India cute our McNuggets
start at four then you got six 10 20 and
not to be done booya 40 McNuggets all
the math heads watching will be quick to
point out that that is double India's
largest nugget option the only burger
that India shares with the US is the
mech chicken The Humble Mech chicken not
even going to bother with the analog
scale now
whoop 149 G ah this so frustrating just
one more gram it would be perfect with
the paper I mean we'll do this
and shave off an eighth of an ounce our
McChicken weighs 140
[Music]
G yo do everything you'll find on the
menu at McDonald's India that you will
not find in the USA and here's all the
McDonald's menu items from the US us you
won't find in India here in India we
can't really recreate the iconic
McDonald's Big Mac because it's made
from a beef patty and to keep to the
religious Sentiments of Hindus and even
Muslims we don't serve beef or pork in a
lot of fast food restaurants we have
something called the chicken Maharaja
Mac as you can see it's got three buns
two patties a lot of cheese and
mayonnaise some tomatoes onions lettuce
let us try it now
[Music]
oh my God that is truly a Maharaja Mac
if you're wondering a Raja is a king and
a Maharaja is like an emperor so this is
clearly our answer to the Big Mac now
let's taste the veg Maharaja Mac I think
it's actually a very cool challenge that
a lot of fast food restaurants here have
had to adapt to the Indian pallet as
well as sensibilities of food we have
come up with such cool iconic fast food
that you won't get anywhere else in the
world like look at this this is
outrageous there's no way to eat this
without being messy there's literally no
way M oh my God that's really good yes
to all that looks really good because of
India's lack of beef all the American
beef options are technical
exclusives all right Big Mac there it is
just brimming with stuff my go-to for
like 20 years I still get it
occasionally the classic McDonald's
hamburger beef patty ketchup and mustard
of course and get it with cheese hi you
can upgrade to a double cheeseburger or
a McDouble what's the difference you ask
I'm not sure either so let's start with
the double cheeseburger look at that
look how yellow that is beef cheese beef
cheese tapos the McDouble is beef cheese
beef so it's just one slice of cheese in
the middle but not on top what's the
price difference can we get that on
screen and how much is a slice of
cheese Joe's hack get yourself a
McDouble and bring your own slice of
American cheese booah save yourself this
amount of money problem with Millennials
today the reason you guys can't buy
houses is you're spending all your money
at Starbucks you're getting your double
cheeseburgers instead of a McDouble and
bring in your own cheese slice I mean
you guys are terrible with money what
you're eating what seven eight McDoubles
a day like me right that adds up to like
at the end of the year $18 10,000 years
later that's a down payment on a
house what are you guys doing all right
next up is the iconic maalu ticki Burger
you take mashed potato and you fry it in
breadcrumbs and you get this really
delicious cutlet here in India they
adapted it into this burger with a very
special sauce some tomato and chopped
onions m M it's just so classic they na
this burger next up there is a Mexican
maalu tii which I assume has um
stereotypical Mexican ingredients and
flavors like jalapeno yes
jalapeno nice it's way more spicy good
twist next up they have a Mech egg
burger Mech egg Mech egg Mech egg I
don't know why I did that let's see what
that looks like ooh sorry I did not
expect like pesto next up is a chicken
kebab Burger every time an Indian fast
food chain tries to adapt an Indian
special food into a burger I take it
with a pinch of salt because this is not
what we're used to seeing when we think
of Kebabs but I'm going to try it and
let's see what happens M it's very very
dry Patty has almost like a cardboard e
taste to it I wouldn't put those flavors
together if I was thinking Kebab make
cardboard Ticky Maybe no okay that's a
bit harsh I'm sorry next up is the mech
veggie which is the vegetarian
counterpart to our Mech chicken if I had
to eat this versus the Chicken one I
would not be upset at all really good
next up we have two American Burgers the
American cheese Supreme wedge and the
American cheese Supreme chicken my hunch
for what makes them American is that
they will have a nice big square of
cheese and they will not be spicy at all
except they have a lot of alpinos on
them Joe let me know if this constitutes
American that's American cheese my man
that's what makes it American I don't
know about those other toppings but yeah
it sounds about right all right so this
is what the McDonald's website sayses in
this burger whole wheat bun SS from
Maharashtra Tangy alapo from Karnataka
shredded onions grown in local Indian
farms and cheese from amaravati also in
India quite quite close to home this
burger currently this would probably be
my favorite order a mix spicy chicken
and there's the vegetarian option which
is a Mech spicy paneer which is just
leaking lettuce for those of you who
don't know what paneer is it's basically
cottage cheese we love our paneer we put
it in curries we eat it plain we put it
in kebabs it is so delicious let's try
this m has just the right kick and it
goes really well with the paneer fair
warning while this may have a light kick
of spice for us it might be a hard kick
for you so take everything with a pinch
of chili F going to move up to something
called the quarter pounder and that's
like their big burger so you can get a
quarter pounder with cheese here it is I
mean this looks it looks fake right like
just kidding it's cake or this is the
new one is a it's actually a candle and
then you can get qu pound with cheese
deluxe more veggies on it all the junk
that I brush off you can upgrade to a
Double Quarter part with cheese let take
a look oh man look how thick this is and
then you can get that same double with
bacon yeah oh man skimping on the bacon
guys what we lack in beef burgers we
make up for in Gourmet Burgers that's
right here in McDonald's India we have
our own collection of Chef special
Gourmet Burgers delicious and I think
this is a rolling menu I think they
introduce new things from time to time
the bun themselves look a lot more
Gourmet you know there's nice riff down
the middle kind of looks like a butt uh
but that's okay we're not going to
concentrate on that first up we have
triple cheese American veg burger and
triple cheese American chicken burger
same thing cheese alpen some sauce
lettuce simple chicken patty a gourmet
bun does this cream American to you next
up cheese lava American veg burger and
cheese lava American chicken burger
again with American and again with the
with a Strange Relation of food to
volcanoes and
lava okay this bger is very spicy this
qualifies as a as a volcano product for
sure congratulations McDonald's the lava
in the title of this Burger Works the
Mec spicy chicken premium though has an
egg Patty inside of
it m that's pretty good
I just feel so existential right
now imagine sitting here at this table
and just tasting every single burger and
McDonald's
menu amazing but
also we also have some exclusive wrap
options we have big spicy paneer and big
spicy chicken I think this is the same
Mex spicy chicken patty and it's wrapped
around a tortilla Which is actually way
closer to an Indian chapati than most
other fast food restaurants it doesn't
doesn't feel as synthetic our McDonald's
in the US had wraps for a brief period
of time one day they were gone nobody
noticed yeah you guys got some chicken
stuff that we don't have but we got a
few of our own more recently than you
think they finally introduced their
chicken sandwich to an already crowded
chicken sandwich market and that is of
course their crispy chicken sandwich and
this thing is fantastic it's one of the
best ones they relate to the game and
they kind of took it over in my opinion
now what I like about it it's simple
look at this you just got crispy chicken
pickles that suck it's baller tastes
great like it a little spicy India it
probably doesn't compare to way you guys
are rocking in India but you know this
one has a little nice heat to it pickles
sauce want to take it up a notch got to
go Deluxe the cool crispness of the
vegetables just Clash so well with the
spicy sauce it's good it's good nille
say the word and I'm putting one in the
post for you to tomorrow so when it
arrives in 3 weeks you can throw it out
now we're getting into exclusive side
dishes here in India we have these
add-ons number one the veg Pizza mcpuff
this is one of the most delicious things
we have here it's basically a pizza hot
pocket Masala vegges these are potato
vegges with classic Indian Masala flavor
to them ooh boy masalas are basically
what we use to spice and flavor dishes
and they consist primarily of ground up
spices like cardum cloves red chilies
Kashmir chilies you go to Every Indian
home the moms the grand moms will have
their own random you know Masala mix
that they use and that's guarded and
treasured in their family forever next
up we have cheesy Masala vegges they're
also serving a classic cup of boiled
corn which is so unique and they give
you a side of amul butter uh guys amul
butter is part of our culture McAn
McAn this is probably going to be the
most delicious bite of the
[Music]
day I love corn next up chicken strips
they come in packs of two three or five
cheesy nugget vegge bites yeah this is
just a vegetarian version of the chicken
nuggets and it's got some corn some
tomato M it's okay next we have the
double cheese McMuffin
and lastly we have Mexican cheesy fries
on the McDonald's India website one
British customer said that these Mexican
cheesy fries are the real deal I have no
idea how a British person can say that
Mexican cheesy fries are the real deal
but anytime a British person says that
another cultures food is the real deal
it puts a little fear in our small
Indian Hearts yeah those fries look like
ass and the next exclusive side that we
have is apple
slices cut them up put them in a plastic
bag About to Get Saucy that's right
ladies and
gentlemen sauce
talk thank
you spicy
BB that look good we got a Tangy
barbecue
oo much better M honey
mustard tastes like salad dressing sweet
sour I would tie with the Tangy barbecue
cuz it's so different so we'll keep
these guys sent tier Ranch I don't know
Amer we love our ranch ranch is just
okay that's why I said it Ranch is just
okay oh and all Ranch tastes the same
yeah and finally
honey how you like that honey is the
best one and all that money all that
energy all that time creating all these
recipes PES trying to sway the American
po the American mind and you got you got
beat by a bunch of
bees power to the
bees we have one exclusive spice mix as
well as One exclusive sauce here in
India we have chili sauce which is
pretty straightforward it's chili sauce
but let me tell you about Peri Peri
spice mix so McDonald's launched this in
2013 here in India and it was so popular
there were riots when they said they
we're going to discontinue it and so now
it's a permanent addition to the menu
first you get this shake bag then you
grab your fries and then you just pour
that in there
ah boom oh boy can we cut to a before of
the fries you saw how they were now look
at these you can see the little Flex of
spice just Ador learning each
[Music]
frame hello it's cristelle and I know
nille has Perry Perry McDonald's chips
but in the UK it is all about Nando
chekin andos let's talk about Perry
Perry Perry means pepper and it's a
blend of spices so it's got things like
paprika ground birds like chili a bit of
oregano a pinch of Ginger and cardamon
but it's a Portuguese spice blend it's
funny because obviously nil mentioned
that the Peri Perry fries just blew off
in India and it makes sense because I'm
from Goa which is in the south of India
Goa was colonized by the Portuguese and
so I really think the Indians are
accustomed to that Portuguese taste
palette which is why Perry Perry fries
are doing so well in India but after the
talking I want to dig into these fries
because they look
great oh this is so good hurry get
involved not eating chips without me are
you no sorry I've already had a head
start Cheers
Cheers God damn if that isn't like crack
for the early risers there's plenty of
exclusive breakfast items at the US
McDonald's sausage biscuit with egg next
one sausage biscuit I mean they take the
egg out so it's just this of course is
bacon egg and
cheese ladies and gentlemen we've
reached the point of the breakfast where
we get into the MCG griddles I love MCG
griddles what's a MC griddle you ask
India fantastic question McDonald's had
this genius idea to plac the breakfast
sandwiches they already had with
pancakes and they also like inject syrup
into it somehow but it is a breakfast
sandwich with pancakes for buns and it's
the best idea anyone's ever had anywhere
ever look at this look at this look at
this got like a little m in there this
mini pancake I know I'm wearing the
gloves but this one's
fine we have a wedge McMuffin and a
sausage
McMuffin M the sausage here in India is
not made out of pork like it is in the
US instead it's made out of simple
chicken speaking of sausage you can get
breakfast
burrito bro I could put five of these
away easy easy you're like a total drag
and you want oatmeal in the morning we
have it it's about as inspiring as you
would think hot cakes and sausage of
course it comes with hot SA Sy up this
here the big breakfast with hot cakes
and it's big lot of eggs kind of wimpy
looking bacon got yourself two English
muffins here and of course comes with
hash brown potatoes who doesn't love
themel hash brown undefeated these
things are so good India exclusive
desserts we have a black forest McFlurry
a vanilla chocolate muffin and a
chocolate chip muffin it's kind of like
a MEC flurry soup right
now this would be really good when it
was actually a MEC flurry desserts USA
we got them so starting down here very
simple CH ship cookies uh this next
thing apple fritter
right M this right here is called a
glazed pull apart dut blueberry muffin
if you had one you've had them all this
is a what type of pie guava and cream
pie let's see what's inside okay I'm
suddenly more interested yay yeah guava
and cream how about we'll call it the
cream and guava pie n this
sucks I it standard menu item the
McDonald's apple pie everyone knows
about this I don't want a pizza version
of this and last but not least cinnamon
roll too sticky I don't feel like eating
it update it's not sticky it's
actually exclusive drinks starting with
with we have something called be
Naturals mixed fruit juice next up we
have something that they call Raw mango
fruit
Splash oh it's a bit too sweet Berry
lemonade Splash all of these come in
these very unique reusable bottles
apparently next up strawberry Chiller
green apple Chiller and lemon
Chiller is this flavored water that's
exactly what it is it's flavored water
and I kind of like it this is a mixed
berry
smoothie it's still quite sweet but
quite good next up American mud pie
shake
M that's pretty umum drink roulette o
and the ice melted fantastic Dr Pepper
let's go Coke not exclusive let's go
sweet tea too
sweet oh yeah unsweetened teen that's
sweet enough you guys combine for the
kids watching why are you watching where
are your parents or supervisors you can
get yourself apple juice milk come on
drinking milk the thought of drinking
straight milk like hurts my stomach
there's also chocolate milk on the menu
Once Upon a Time this was an iced french
vanilla latte now it's more of a room
temperature French vanilla
latte it's just okay it's like really
like really sweet strawberry banana
smoothie yeah I always always love
getting these These are good so I'm
going to assume they're not good for me
exclusive hot drinks first off we have
strawberry green tea next up uh English
breakfast tea and Moroccan tea next up a
flat white coffee India a land where we
run on chai and McDonald's does not have
a chai option caramel macchiato
capuccino caramel latte a vanilla
cappuccino the F with the V does look
like a you McDonald's premium roast
coffee I'm going to hang on to this
one in India a chicken Maharaja Mac will
cost you 231 rupees for just a sandwich
that's around $
3.03 we do not have the chicken Maharaja
Mac but we do have the Big Mac and a Big
Mac in the US cost
$4.89 that is a 61% price increase now
what if you turn this into a meal a mea
Maharaja ma combo comes with regular
fries and a regular drink and will cost
you 356 rupees that is $
4.67 still less than the price of the
American Sandwich on its own but does
the combo meal make a difference in the
US a medium Big Mac combo so Big Mac
medium fries medium drank is
$8.99 that's a
92% cost increase even worse than if you
just bought the sandwich on its own on
the Indian McDonald's menu you'll find a
twers meal which contains a chicken m
Maharaja Mac a veg Maharaja Mac large
fries two Pizza Mech Puffs and a drink
all of this will cost you 681 rupees or
8.93 so basically you're getting food
for two people for the price of one
person's meal in the US however while
the seems a lot cheaper than the food in
the US it's still very expensive and
aspirational to people over here your
minimum wage per hour is equal to our
daily minimum wage and so yeah a lot of
people can't really afford this kind of
food the English-speaking Indians that
you see in a lot of YouTube videos on
the internet aren't really a proper
reflection of the majority of people
that live in this country who still
can't afford food like this so I'm
checking my privilege and we should all
make sure we check ours but let's play
Devil's Advocate McDonald's India has
definitely included a lot more
affordable options on their menu and so
they are more approachable to the
average Urban Indian than other fast
food
chains let's compare some items to see
who has the least healthy McDonald's
food in the US a McChicken contains 400
calories 21 G of fat 39 G of carbs five
of those are sugar and 560 Mig of sodium
how about the Indian MEC chicken one of
these contains 398 calories 15 G of
total fat 48 G of carbs 5 G of which are
sugars 787 mg of sodium so the Indian
version has slightly fewer calories way
lesser fats but much more carbs and
sodium what if we made that a combo meal
well a medium fry in the US contains the
following 320 calories 15 G of total fat
43 G of carbs no sugar and 260 mg of
sodium while a medium fries in India
contains 340 calories 17 G of total fat
41 G of carbs 0 g of sugars and 256 mg
of sodium and if we add the medium Coke
that is adding 210 calories no fat 56
gram of carbs 56 of those are sugar and
55 mg of sodium ooh a nice salty Coke
we'll do the same here in India one
medium Coke will cost you 1501 calories
0 g of fat 38 G of carbs 38 G of which
are sugars and there are 0 g of sodium
but my God that is a lot of sugar packed
in this cup that leaves the Indian meal
at a grand total of of 889 calories 32 G
of fat 127 G of carbs out of which 43 G
of sugars and 1,43 mg of sodium sheesh
which means this whole bad boy Al
together is 930 calories 36 gr of total
fat 138 gram of carbs 61 of those grams
are sugar 875 Mig of sodium little bit
lower sodium than India but we got you
guys beat in C C fats carbs and
sugar we win we
win unfortunately for India the combo
stats are a little misleading and the
Difference Maker is the coke because the
American meal has a larger portion if
you order the Coke Zero in both
countries the Indian meal will actually
have a higher calorie
count McDonald's India does not share a
full list of their ingredients but there
are some things we do know about their
food did you know that McDonald's India
actually changed Indian farming
practices just so they could grow the
kind of potato that they wanted when
they first launched in India 1996
McDonald's promised the government that
they would use products grown and
sourced right here in India but people
who had eaten McDonald's abroad realized
that the fries didn't taste quite the
same the reason for this is that Indian
potatoes were too small around had way
too much moisture and sugar content and
so the fries made out of them were not
long enough they didn't get crispy
enough and they didn't have that dis
instinctive McDonald's oomph to them so
McDonald's partnered with mcain foods
and they spent 9 years trying to perfect
their potato they imported saplings
which had the perfect shape and starch
content that they needed they also chose
Gujarat as their farming location for
its climate and they switched from a
flood irrigation to a sprinkler system
to reduce moisture content and save
water the result bigger and more starchy
potatoes that can be used to make the
McDonald's fries that you know and love
McDonald's in the US mostly uses rusted
Burbank or sheepy sheepy potatoes potato
me so these are big enough have the
stinc of long fry yeah look how long
this is WoW known to be low moisture and
low sugar content this means they can
remain crispy when fried and don't
caramelize too fast so you can get a
nice even Browning McDonald's in the US
actually discloses all of its
ingredients so we can figure out a few
other differences in the US for instance
our mayonnaise contains AO as does most
American Mayo thanks to the FAQ page on
the McDonald's India website we found
out that the mayonnaise is eggless along
with all of the other sauces except for
the tartar sauce when people describe
things as vegetarian here in India they
typically mean it doesn't contain
egg from calorie count to portion sizes
we want to find out all the differences
between McDonald's in Japan and the US
this is food
Wars
hey guys Joe from food Wars we're doing
a new season we're comparing the US to
Japan order to do that I want to
introduce you to co-host and my man in
Japan George hello guys I'm George I'm
from Japan and I like
[Music]
McDonald's so in Japan our McDonald's
sodas come in three sizes this is small
small and this is Japan's medium medium
and this one is Japan large
large in Japan our chicken McNuggets
come in five and 15 pieces our chicken
McNuggets come in four six 10 20 or 40
piece look at all those
nuggets oh you've been sitting for a
while Japan McDonald's fries come in
three sizes small small medium and large
in the US you get your fries in four
sizes kids small medium and large what
is little guy look at this little guy so
this is large fries and I'm going to
weigh them we are going to also weigh a
large McDonald's fry wow okay so so far
our larges are the same yeah wow that
worked perfectly the thing I just did
there great job Joe
go
go now let's measure the medium why why
not are mediums are smaller H
interesting so this is a Japanese big ma
Tada
oh so this is a Japanese bigm this is an
American Big Mac and we're going to
weigh it as well now we got a heftier
Big Mac here in the US it's more like it
it's in Japan the bigm body set which is
a bigmk and medium fries and a medium
drink comes out to 6 0 y or
$621 in the US that same meal cost
$854 or
9484 Japanese Yen that's a
3752 increase in price in the US what
the
heck so here is everything you can only
get a Japan's McDonald's you can know
get in the US and this is everything you
can get at a US McDonald's that you
cannot get in Japan so we are going to
start with waffle cor right here so we
got plain so plain means it's like Rich
milk taste and next one is strawberry
strawberry personally I like this and
next one is chocolate and almond right
there H it's not melting good job buddy
so here we've got MC flow so M Flo means
there's soda and on top of that there
ice cream that's it that's it and this
is MC FRS
melon
W it's too sweet this is grap coffee Mac
floats M and the last one we've got Coke
M
floats oh Joe you definitely try this
yes absolutely I'm trying that when I go
to Japan that looks real good let me
think here hang on a
second
okay we do not have MC floats here in
the US so I'm going to make my own on my
way over here I was looking for grape
soda it's actually harder to find than I
thought Fanta is not very popular in the
United States but we got this this is
midnight grape Kickstarter Mountain Dew
it's
[Music]
grape aha left over from the Ben and
Jerry shoot stuff is frozen here we
[Music]
go yeah I'm into this these would do
well in the US our coold drinks a little
bit different uh we have two exclusive
slushies that you can't get in Japan one
is a pink lemonade strawberry watermelon
yeah dude looks real good yes they do
have McFlurries and ice cream in Japan
but one McFlurry you can get in the US
is this one it's M&M's McFlurry sorry
it's since melted but it's like those uh
those mini M&M's I went to one of the
few McDonald's in the country where the
ice cream machine was working hot
caramel Sunday and the classic fudge
Sunday so let's go with soft drinks
right here F the grape and here is Fanta
melon and this one is Japanese vegetable
juice and there is I guess more than 20
or 30 vegetables in it and it's good for
health for
sure we've got C white grape so kicha so
K is like a Japanese Blended tea it's
healthy and Japanese people drink this
on a daily basis so next one we've got
all gray IC tea let me show you wait
there is
something there's a
mosquito I have to make a complaint
Japan
McDonald's next one we've got ulong tea
so this is not actually Japanese tea
it's a Chinese tea that's good for
health as well for health we do have a
mangle pineapple smoothie and a banana
strawberry smoothie smoothies have fruit
in it
right oh yeah I can just feel the
nutrients coarsing through my
veins so let's start with this Hawaiian
menu this is limited this one right here
is cheese loomo oh it's
messy it's a damic glass sauce man and
it's also got round egg right there beef
potty and some cheese I'm hungry
actually oh this is good
oh he looks so
happy this is H which means really
really delicious first the next one
we've got garlic shrimp and it's also
got interesting bun there is Sesame on
there and um deep fried shrimp hawaian
barbecue potato and
beef demig glass sauce again it's going
to be
good this is called barbecue burger
right but I don't taste barbecue at all
all right so next one we've got hawaian
pancake with Triple Berry sauce two
pancakes
hello M smells so sweet oo let's
[Music]
go too sweet Mac face Blue Hawaii wow it
has bright blue
color this is Mac face casis and
orange
I would get this I would get this so
congratulations this is the
worst okay breakfast time this is a
breakfast burrito oh neon yellow egg
Mexican style salsa not to be confused
with what Canadian
salsa this is actually the same burrito
from the US UK thing we shot over a year
ago so let's go on to these breakfast
sandwiches here Japan does have the MC
riddles which are favorite of mine so
unfortunately we will not be talking
about those today so I love you MC
riddles so what they don't have and also
the UK did not have were our breakfast
biscuit sandwiches I don't know how to
describe a biscuit other than it's dry
it's baked maybe they're made with
cornmeal according to the internet this
is not a scone so there you go sausage
egg and cheese our egg is like this
fluffy full did scramble egg egg so
there's like Sunny Side Up ours are
scrambled I can tell this was like
folded over you can see like the fold
lines there this is how we do it in the
US bacon egg and cheese is there a
better breakfast combination in the
world I don't think there is then they
just have the sausage no egg no cheese
just sausage and biscuit we have regular
size hot cakes and we have a hot cake
and sausage combo and of
course comes with syrup and
butter
very natural pose very natural feeling
right now always up for a PO
yes breakfast is served oatmeal on the
side to be mixed in cranberries and
raisins and diced
oh diced
apples and here we've got Mega muffin
pork potties that's huge one
mini pancakes oh cute it comes with
apple cream
sauce
[Music]
ooh ooh this is perfect for breakfast I
would get it bacon egg MX sandwich so
it's got bacon and round egg and cheddar
cheese that's it and you might be
surprised we've got FL fish
TDA so fill fish is on the breakfast
menu I guess Japanese people tend to eat
fish for your breakfast three exclusive
Burgers here in the US are variations on
the quarter pounder with cheese yes
we've all seen Pulp Fiction we know
about the whole quarter Ponder thing
does not exist outside of the US I don't
think so probably why they don't have
quarter Ponders in Japan the classic
quarter pounder with cheese look at this
guy I mean this is maybe my go-to one
for a decade the quarter Pounder with
cheese deluxe I don't know I feel like
this is pretty close to a Whopper I'm
not a big Whopper guy but there you go a
deluxe quar pound of with cheese the
double quarter pound of with cheese look
at the size of this thing yes sir Japan
exclusive Burgers Teriyaki Mac burger
which is my most favorite one my body is
made of Mac teria
Burger
[Laughter]
so it's got a Mayo right there a lettuce
pork patties dip it into delicious terx
sace and it's covering Whole pork
patties perfectly Joe when you come to
Japan please try this you will thank me
later everything that they have looks so
good and sounds so good man when I go to
Tokyo first stop I'm going to McDonald's
Sushi Ramen get it out of my face I want
the teriyaki burger that's the first
thing I'm getting when I get
there I'm getting FL
jelly look at F dude slow on George we
got a lot of food to
cover wel to food
baby all right so we've got bacon
lettuce burger right here it looks
sad
egg cheeseburger but we also call it
eguchi egui is an abbreviation for egg
cheeseburger Japanese people love
abbreviation it's got ketchup and pickle
round egg and cheddar cheese and beef
patties next one spicy beef burger ooh
look at this oh looks so spicy ESP spicy
mayo or something like that so here
we've got Samurai Muk
samurai samurai Mac yo that sounds
awesome and this blue one is called
roasted soy sauce double thick beef
we've got roasted soy sauce bacon tomato
thick beef so if you want a little bit
more like healthy
veggies go for it uh yeah George I don't
know if that makes that much healthier
there cuz it also has twice as much meat
and cheese if you're looking to be
healthy at a McDonald's in Japan I'd
stick with the vegetable juice and this
one right here is called teraki chicken
filo wow so much sauce so next one we've
got Abby filo Abby means shrimp so it's
a shrimp filo oh yeah it's got Aurora
sauce auroraa sauce is like a ketchup
and mayonnaise so it's got a lot of
shrimp in
there m so good so good in the US we
have about four uh exclusive chicken
sandwiches specifically I didn't see
this on the menu but apparently you guys
don't have a McChicken which is just
chicken sandwich uh regular bun Mayo
[Music]
chicken we also have check this out
spicy
McChicken so pretty much the same
McChicken but like they put spicy
coating on the breading on the chicken
every fast food chain in America right
now is having what we're calling the
Fried Chicken Sandwich Wars Popeyes uh
Burger King of course McDonald's all of
them are this arms race to have the best
chicken sandwich I think his Chick-fil-A
has edged everyone out these are the
three that are currently available I
don't know for how long we have the
crispy chicken sandwich things is a BOS
bun uh
pickles and no sauce which I think is
strange like the the whole flavor is
just just the chicken spicy chicken
sandwich same deal but of course spicy
sauce and the spicy chicken Deluxe which
to George's Point has more vegetables on
it you know to be
healthier okay so when it comes to C
menus we've got Shaka Shaka
chicken and we have two Flav oh two
flavors can you he that thunder thunder
thunder cuz it's rainy season in Japan
the sunny season season here in Southern
California and here is rra pepper and
this one is cheddar
cheese ther stop so all you have to do
is just put the powder into the back and
shake
it and the powder should be cover in the
whole Shaka Chicken ooh big one like
this
[Music]
this I've seen before this I want that's
the thing I want the most of the
Japanese McDonald's us McDonald's we
have the bags we have the chicken just
get the spice packets throw one in we've
got side solad and it comes with this
rosed sesame dressing let's go
ooh that was cool now put it all in the
garbage we've got
Adam and
corn yogurt and there's cow cow
exclusive sauces it's sauce talk time
sauce talk we have sweet and sour sauce
they gave me hot mustard that's supposed
to be honey mustard you guys have Hot
Mustard I know you don't have honey
mustard of course
Ranch uh ooh spicy
buffalo now these might be promotions
cuz of that uh singing group BTS but we
have right now a Cajun sauce and a sweet
chili sauce this sauce is
fantastic this is the sauce this has to
stay in the menu so these two are new
ones this one right here is soy sauce
best
sauce man this is fantastic good job
very good taste so this one right here
is called Louisiana hos ooh it does look
like very spicy
[Music]
one this is not spicy at all actually we
were supposed to have buy Burger options
but unfortunately you can only get them
from 5:30 p.m. but let me explain what
by Burger is by simply means double in
Japanese so if you order a normal Big
Mac it has two big parties right but if
you order buy big Muk it has four beef
patties but not not only big Muk but all
burgers and adapts the buy Burger
options that's funny you can only get
double the meat after 5:30 that's really
funny that would not stand in this
country at all people would lose their
minds four patties once a Big Mac so
after shooting this video I'm going to
order buy Big Mac and then bye bye
Health you ain't got to tell me George
bye health
all right here are all the ingredients
for us Big Mac oh God the bun it has
enriched flow which is wheat
flour vinegar and contains wheat onto
the beef patty 100% pure U SDA inspected
beef no fillers no extenders prepared on
the grill with seasoning salt and black
pepper there you go there you go treaded
lettuce ingredients lettuce nice the Big
Mac sauce ingredients soybean
oil extractives of paprika soy
lein the pickle slice ingredients
cucumbers water distilled vinegar salt
calcium chloride Alum potassium sorbate
preservative natural flavors poly orbid
80 extractives of turmeric for color
onion ingredients onions there you go
few things I want to note Alum is used
to dissolve steel poly sorbet 80 has
been linked linked to colon cancer in
mice cue the dancing
mice and caramel color is on
California's list of chemicals that may
cause cancer and reproductive toxicity
good God Counterpoint they all taste
fantastic so McDonald's Japan doesn't
disclose their ingredients in the big MK
however they do tell us where the
ingredients come from if you order a big
mug in Japan you'll eat beef from
Australia or New Zealand buns made from
wheat imported from the USA Canada and
Australia and pickles made from
cucumbers grown in Turkey Sri Lanka or
India onions grown in the USA or India
slic cheddar cheese made in New Zealand
Australia the USA or Japan and Lettuce
grown in Japan Taiwan the USA or
Malaysia the only ingredients that come
from Japan are the cheese and the
lettuce and even then McDonald's still
Imports some lettuce and cheese from
other countries so this is a very
International
Burger thank you
world so in Japan Our Big Mac is 525
calories and 28.3 G of fat in
1,7 mg of sodium and 41.8 G of carbs and
26 g of protein in the US Our Big Mac is
550 calories 30 G of fat 1,10 mg of
sodium 45 G of carbs and 25 g of protein
so the US has a slight increase on
everything except protein so in Japan
our five piece nuggets is 270 calories
and 17.2 G of fat and 56 mg of sodium
and 13.1 G of curb her and 15.8 g of
protein broken down each nugget is 54
calories we don't have a five piece here
in the us but we do have this a 10 piece
let's get those stats on the screen go
ahead and divide everything by two and
yes now we have the stats for a five
piece pretty smart e if we want to
divide all that by I think five you'll
get the stats for one nugget this is so
exhausting in Japan if you order a big
McMill with large fries and a medium
chocolate shake the ground to will be
1,45 calories and in the US adding
medium fries and a medium chocolate
shake to a Big Mac the grand total is
1660 calories and that is a calorie
increase of
18.14% if you're wondering why we're
using a large fried but a medium
chocolate shake turns out that in Japan
you can't get a large chocolate shake
the only salty in medium I'm assuming
because I don't want eating that much
ice
cream from calorie counts and Portion
sizes we want it find all the
differences between McDonald's in the US
and China this is food
Wars new season USA versus China I'm so
excited for you guys to see this and to
meet our new co-host tinin USA versus
China let's
go drinks from McDonald's in China come
in three sizes small medium and big but
for some reason the medium is 444 ml
which in Chinese basically just means
die die die which is super unlucky so I
guess they really want you to either get
the large or the SW the drinks of the US
McDonald's come in four sizes the extra
small where'd it go sorry they forgot it
the small the medium and the large our
large is
80.9% bigger than China's largest soda
let's see if that's true bound to be a
little bit in the
lid that is Blasphemous shame these
people shame this clown some of you over
the past several years has said
something to the tune of it doesn't
count or it's wrong because we add the
ice or we keep the ice in there and that
isn't a true measurement which I don't
believe but fine for the first time ever
I want to measure this without the ice
so I'm solving this once and for all so
right away you get even less soda let's
get this up to exactly 32 fluid oz 32 o
Coca-Cola in the supposed 32 oz
McDonald's cup I'm so sick of this why
are they saying 32 fluid ounces look
just say 30 or or 31 it's fine you're
move McDonald's our fries come in three
sizes small medium and large American
fries come in three sizes small medium
and large we will now weigh our largest
fry so what about McNuggets here in
China you can only get them as an order
of five or 10 which is really just two
portions of five that's cute China real
cute here in the US we have way many
more nugget options four piece for your
infant six piece 10 piece 20 piece and
our largest the 40 piece all the math
heads watching will be quick to point
out that this is
300% of China's largest
portion so here are all the McDonald's
menu items from China that you won't
find in the US here are all the
McDonald's items in the US you won't
find in China oh my god I've been
staring at this for so long this is
incredible check out the back it's an
origami Apple this is the best and see
what we got a hamburger mini fries a
drink a corn
cup PN oh my God this is way better than
the Hamburglar w
do I have to build Pon as well this
is I'm too of for this anyway if you
don't want a hamburger you can also
change this out for a fish fillet or for
four pieces of nuggets you can also get
the corn cup changed out for apple
slices but they will cost you one quite
extra and with the juice you can have
either apple juice milk or water so only
healthy options here in as McDonald's
okay now on for the toy so this is going
to take a while give me a
second and then something flips out from
behind his groin in here it's coming
together
oh it's a basketball hoop oh my God this
is ingenuity at its f look we can play
Hoops with this 3 2
1 I noticed that his Happy Meal even the
box was a toy in America our Happy Meal
box is another opportunity for an
advertisement all new season of the mass
singer on Fox check it out Jesus is
Shameless these kids remember before the
extra small fry found it more nuggets a
four piece apple slices our toy is
decidedly not a puzzle remember when
Kermit the Frog was in there that was
weird okay what is this who what
celebrity was the fox oh it's Wayne
Brady okay I've heard of him is his head
in here oddly enough shows the Stark
difference between China and the US
theirs has this puzzle to put together
ours as an ad for a TV
show okay so these are our exclusive
beef burgers here in China people mostly
eat pork so I think with the beef
they've really had to go the premium
route so you've got some interesting
combinations this is the German sausage
double beef burger but in Chinese the
name is kind of like the
anti-vegetarian Tyrant so they've got
some pretty aggressive marketing for
this imagine tering Cru just ping his
pecs all e what is that oh if this is
what they call a German sausage then I
think the Germans will be very angry
here we've got a BT double beef
burer I'm so sad what is this this is
like a BLT sandwich that's been set at
the bottom of your bag for a week I'm
excited about these though these are the
Angus Max thick beef burgers now
McDonald's have done premium
collaborations with Michelin stard chefs
in the past and they even have these
really super fancy packaging look at
that double
cheeseburger wow look at that a meat
Patty thicker than my thumb that's a
proper Burger M it was very meaty
incredibly cheesy this is the double
cheeseburger so I can understand that
for the vast majority of Chinese people
their understanding or access to Western
food May really come from fast food
restaurants so this is probably the
gourmet burger experience for the vast
majority of the Chinese population in
the US you can get a quarter pounder
with cheese what the heck they us two
two Taps this is the special two top
Quarter Pounder which is apparently and
we also have a Double Quarter Pounder if
you want toat increase the meat someone
wants to get their daily vegetables here
is the quarter po OFA cheese deluxe
swimming in mayonnaise be something in
United States called the McDouble if you
want slightly less cheese on a double
cheeseburger we got you cover quarter
pounder with bacon every once in a while
they take a quar pounder and put bacon
on it and I they they repackage it for a
celebrity and these are our exclusive
chicken and fish options so I want to
start you off with this which has since
become McDonald's best spicy Burger this
is the mcspicy chicken fet
apparently it's
1,000 Shu which is a scoval unit and
it's roughly equivalent to the spiciness
you get from a spicy and numbing hot pot
and those guys are pretty
spicy oh that's delicious you don't feel
the burn at first and then it's like
your tongue slowly starts to wake up and
it's like a frog in a pot it slowly
starts to realize it's being boiled
alive and by the end of this burger
you're going to want that cook now this
is McDonald's bestselling nons spicy
Burger the grilled chicken sandwich
which is supposedly has no grow hormones
in their chicken
feed very heavy on the black pepper wow
I'm very excited about this this is the
MCR crunch chicken filet burger and in
Chinese the name is k it sounds like how
it's supposed to say k is kind of like
crunchy and is kind of like the juice
kind of squirting out so this should be
both crunchy and juicy see o that looks
like a much better piece of
chicken yes yes I didn't get the car
probably because this has gone a bit
cold but look at that it is Juicy in
there okay this is the super spicy
chicken Fila look at this guy you know
this is going to be super spicy it's
orange it's not that
spicy this what as oh oh my
God very tasty finish that and it's um
to the hospital you'll go and last but
in my opinion least the double fish
burger chicken sandwiches there's
something that is newish the bacon ranch
mccrispy this just so okay there's also
a bacon ranch Deluxe M Krispy Deluxe
equals more vegetables the M Krispy is
something that we ordered and they
forgot and then now piling on the
vegetables you got the MC Krispy Deluxe
spicy MC Krispy this Rebrand the crispy
chicken sandwich to be the mck
Krispy how spicy canis be isn't that
spicy all
also imag all the stuff on so McDonald's
China has one roll option which is this
crispy pork and pickled bamboo choot
wrap
H that's tasty is nice and crunchy very
spicy
wow M it's spicy it's sour anything that
has suchan peppercorn in it it's just
incredible here we've got the Muk spicy
wings which come in portions of two four
or nine straight up I wish we had those
wings those wings look really good also
I don't know if you've noticed but the
decoration here on the packet this is a
collaboration with a street wear brand
called clot or
clot and uh it uses traditional Chinese
Aesthetics so here you've got the lucky
knot which is sort of like a symbol for
good luck and Longevity as Chinese as it
gets and this is also the same flavor as
the mcspicy burger I don't know if
there's an accurate translation for this
this is literally called such a big
chicken
chop it's about about the same size as
my palm a little bit bigger some a
crispy
chicken m crispy
wow yes this
is very special we didn't think we'd be
able to get this today this is the spicy
Lobster flavored chicken tenders the
Chinese says yao yao which means you
have to shake
it oh let's try these babies there was
no need to shake it at all there's
there's no seasoning there at all it's
just literally it's it's it's just
literally chicken
tenders it's more of a an aspiration
towards Lobster though and we've got
crinkle cut fries oh how I've missed you
nothing beats a crinkle cut fryer in
China we have a bunch of different
Barrel options for example this one is
the Golden Archers buckets which
actually didn't come in a bucket they
just put everything into a box the name
actually is the reason why we got this
because McDonald's in China has
officially renamed to Dingman which
literally translates as golden arches
and when they did that they caught a lot
of flak everybody started laughing at
them nobody calls them the Golden
Archers in Chinese it's it's just
McDonald's but legally they are now
known as The Golden Archers featuring
sources you know what that mean
Julie sauce talk here are all of our
exclusive sauces garlic
chili that's pretty much it oh and no
Satan sauuce either that's an American
invention just like General so's chicken
but here in China you don't really get
sauces unless you ask for them they come
with the Nuggets Chinese people expect
food to be complete when it arrives at
your table you don't go and add more
sauce to it sauces in the United States
ASP themal for dipping Tangy barbecue
spicy buffalo it's the USA so you know
we got that ranch honey mustard honey
which is not here I don't know where it
is mayonnaise which also they did not
include Mexican style salsa these are
our exclusive desserts I am going to try
every single one of them we can start
with the tarot pie tarot is kind of like
a cross between sweet potato and potato
it's often used in desserts in Asia
you'll find them in everything from pies
to Bubble
Tea it's a bit like yam with a bit of
Jam but it's subtly sweet for Chinese
people if you say a dessert is not very
sweet that's actually a compliment
pineapple pie also one of my
favorites that is
Haz I think I'm going to finish this I
to cheer for a very long
time so here we've got the strawberry
sundae which has kind of melted already
but I'm sure it would have been amazing
when it first arrived an afato and a
matcho flavored afato and then here
we've got the
McFlurries this is the strawberry
McFlurry with Oreo cookies oh my gosh
that is perhaps the most sinful thing
that you could have but it's so good
this is just regular McFlurry and here
is my all-time favorite mango pomelo SEO
flavored McFlurry H it's very different
with the ice cream you still got the uh
the mango in there and the p yellow it's
very juicy it's tender like little tiny
Pips in there they kind of Pop when you
eat them oh just
perfect very
fresh in the US you can get yourself a
McFlurry with mini M&M's for some reason
mini M&M's taste better than regular
M&M's I love mini
M&M's hot caramel Sunday this classic
never got this in China yeah I mean
what's more American than an apple pie
look at this thing let's crack that bad
boy open we got chocolate chip cookies
shakes get three different types of
shakes here at us McDonald's
chocolate classic chocolate strawberry
personal
favorite that's so good vanilla the
classic our exclusive drinks include the
fuse IC tea we've got the minute made
orange MC float bubble tea soy milk pure
milk Salon black tea which in China we
would call Red red tea which just
confuses you for fun I'm going to go
back to here cuz this is the only thing
I want to try out of all of
them it tastes like orange juice it's
just plain old orange juice the US to
gives yourself a Dr Pepper a Fanta
orange and an orange lava burst lemonade
you also get frozen drinks get a frozen
Fanta blue raspberry or frozen Coke
McDonald's also has smoothies a mango
pineapple smoothie and a strawberry
smoothie
yeah they make they make a decent smooth
inernal as you can see we have an
absolute ton of breakfast options here
in China I think McDonald's has done
fantastic in this regard because the
Chinese treat breakfast as a very
special meal we have a very similar
saying to eat breakfast like a king
lunch like a prince dinner like a paa so
starting with the sausage McMuffin with
egg always a good way to start the day
you can get this as a double as well
next we have the ham muffin just
literally a piece of ham some lettuce
and two muffins so I guess this would
actually be a hamburger you get this as
a double as well next we have the
grilled chicken
muffin this chicken's been sitting
around for a while next we've got the
the crispy chicken McMuffin so this is
the breakfast version of the such a big
chicken chop breakfast in the US we have
so many breakfast options starting down
here the sandwiches Egg McMuffin maybe
the first fast breakfast sandwich to
ever hit the markets sausage McMuffin
sausage and cheese if you had noticed
this is all U what we call an English
muffin cuz they're from England there's
also a bacon egg and cheese McMuffin but
the option that we have most for are the
scrambled egg Burgers scrambled egg
grilled chicken burger the scrambled egg
is very luminous yellow wow look at
that very peppery they love their pepper
here don't they so scrambled egg sausage
Burger you'll notice the buns are
different now we're no longer on the
muffins we're back to regular buns oh
it's squeezing out isn't it scrambled
egg
cheeseburger this is like the brightest
Burger I've ever seen in my life it's
definitely very portable I think that's
one thing that McDonald's has done very
well cuz Chinese breakfast tradition in
the is is not too portable in the sense
that you need to sit down to a lot of
meals like if you want to eat um one ton
in the morning or if you want to eat
some soups in the morning this you can
just take and go and of course you can
get the scrambled egg German flavor
sausage burger at least they give you
two as opposed to just one tiny sausage
biscuits biscuits biscuits sausage and
egg biscuit so the biscuits are the same
breakfast sandwiches you get in English
muffin form but in this biscuit form the
American biscuit this dry crumbly
buttery biscuits there is a bacon egg
and cheese one for some reason people in
this country seem to want just a
biscuits and sausage with no sauce no
nothing this is as dry as if you'd go
into like a barber shop and take a
handful of hair clippings and just shove
them in your mouth this is that dry in
the US we have something called MCG
griddles and MCG griddles are breakfast
sandwiches where they replace the
English muffin Andor biscuit with
pancakes so first of all they got the
McDonald's logo right there too
hilarious somehow to the miracle of
science was able to inject syrup into
these
pancakes you get your mg griddles in
sausage EG and cheese and then just
sausage on to what I was going to talk
about the conji kji is a very
traditional breakfast item here in China
it's basically just rice porridge and
it's something that is kind of like
Chicken Soup for Chinese people in the
sense that if you fall ill you're going
to be given one of these plain with
nothing this I think is with Century egg
but the century egg it tastes a little
bit like a blue cheese version of egg in
that it's kind of like egg that's gone
off but in a very nice way and this adds
a nice savoriness to the conji you can
also get it with pickles and bamboo
shoots and if you're going to get conji
then usually you need to pair it with
what they called an an Asian dough stick
this is what we call a Yol which is
literally a stick of fried though these
are absolutely amazing when paired with
stuff like soy milk and of course with
Cony no you need to eat these fresh deep
fried they are so incredibly crispy oh
wow well done McDonald's like 10 hours
later these are still crispy I'm very
impressed but also a little bit worried
because they should never be this crispy
after that long I wonder what they've
put in here last but not least my German
sausages again it's not just sandwiches
you guys we also have something in the
US the big breakfast which is totally in
disarray this is this is like the
advertisement for this breakfast I'm
sorry the big breakfast with pancakes
need to get hot cakes AKA pancakes
there's no way they're back there like
ladling the uh right there's no way
they're doing that these have to be
pre-made just heat them up right so hot
cakes and sausage oh and they both come
with syrup so you know what we got to
do yeah we also have a morning wrap with
ham the uh the wrap itself is is
basically frozen solid we can exchange
that with sausage which is also Frozen
it's almost like a piece of art now like
you're supposed to look at it instead of
eating it wow Frozen in time us
McDonald's have sausage breakfast
burritos I mean I can't even unfold I'm
just like ripping it apart you got the
scrambled eggs the sausage it comes with
Mexican style salsa and McDonald's is
actually pretty good considering that
this is like probably the furthest you
can get from something from salsa and
still legally called Salsa if you're not
trying to completely destroy your
insides first thing in the morning you
can get yourself fruits and maple
oatmeal see I feel like your breakfast
is trying to escape your body an hour
later might to be able to hold us down
and voila the options from Le so we have
macarons right now we have two different
flavors chocolate and berries these
actually look really
legit pat yourself on the back this is
really good and these things are
lamingtons I've never actually had
lamingtons apparently they're basically
Australian sponge cakes which are
covered in coconut flakes and this is a
lemon flavor
one surprisingly addictive uh we have
the maafe bakery at the maafe bakery you
get you know sweet treats not
necessarily for breakfast but probably
leaning more towards breakfast time B
bam blueberry muffin a cinnamon roll
with cream cheese frosting it looks like
a
squishy it most certainly is not and
kamama who doesn't love an Apple Fritter
an apple friter is a doughnut that
tastes like apple and it was shaped like
it was just squo in some hand for some
strange reason these are our milk Cafe
drink options starting with the extra
milky latte with oat
milk a latte is 2/3 milk and then you
add oat milk in there I don't think
we're going to have much
coffee oh oh wow that is surprisingly
good in China oat milk is really really
taken off because a lot of people did
not grow up drinking milk a lot of
Chinese people are lactose intolerant
and so oat milk is definitely a very
healthy the alternative that's why we
have the extra strong chocolate with oat
milk you can also get this without oat
milk extra strong matcha milk extra
strong matcha we have so much matcha
extra strong chocolate smoothie extra
strong milk and vanilla smoothie and the
matcha milk with matcha jelly matcha
matcha oh want we absolutely love matcha
here in China I don't know
why tastes like
grass and Frozen grass coffees and
coffees and coffees and coffees
McDonald's has a assortment of feature
drinks espresso drinks mochas ice lattes
let's get all that on the screen see all
these things this is the cold brew this
is so
strong I think each of you should
eventually take a SI you will not
believe how strong the cold brew is oh
my God French vanola latte this is the
exact opposite this is like so sweet
mocha who doesn't want hot chocolate
first thing in the morning hilarious
people are buying that oh this the
premium roast coffee I know I've been
kind of dissent on it but their actual
coffee the actual McDonald's coffee I
think is very good they're they're a
good contender in the coffee game I
think in the fast food coffee game
especially the horrible PR nightmare
they had when they like destroyed that
lady's crotch with their super hot
coffee it is a comeback story McDonald's
almost killing a woman with second
degree burns from boiling hot coffee to
these nice little fun Cafe drinks I
would happily pour this all over my
crotch you can get the um iced coffee
drinks they like this this is the mocha
McDonald's in China also has a late
night menu they only have one item but
this is worth it I got it last night
these are marinated chicken bones they
don't sound very appealing but the
Chinese name is word play on an idiom
which kind of means the highest level of
artistry and when I opened up this
box I literally heard Angels
going this is actually a street food
from some place up in Northeast China
called shinyang Chinese people love
fiddly stuff and meat on the bone is
just that much more
tasty H still incredible even cold you
know the Box actually says marinated
chicken bones be careful may contain
bones and you're actually supposed to to
spit the bones out but I'm having so
much fun eating this thing I actually
eat the bones too it's spicy it's sour
it's sweet oh and just absolutely Divine
I can see how people would be inspired
after eating
this so uh McDonald's came to China in
1990 and then it opened in Beijing in
'92 and back then that was the largest
McDonald's in the world they had 700
seats on opening day they served 40,000
people and people didn't go there for
the food it was a place to be seen like
McDonald's was a window to the West it
was a Cosmopolitan place to experience
capitalism in a way but over time it
became a trendy hangout spot for City
kids after school they go there to do
their homework it still very much is
middle class I remember actually when I
came to visit China 20 years ago uh my
aunts greeted me at at the airport with
bags of McDonald's and I was actually
kind of offended that they would bring
junk food to meet me as oppos the real
Chinese food but for them McDonald's was
the best of the best it was all the
prestige hey to me McDonalds when it
comes with fast food is number one in
the US dare I say the world if you just
want a good hot meal where you know
exactly what's going to taste like and
get it and go McDonald's never fails
waiting in line getting the drive-thru
you get it licky split now they really
they leaned really big into delivery
since Co and man the McDonald's is
showing up right away and I love it it's
dangerous uh I can't remember last time
I've eaten inside at McDonald's so I
usually dine in at McDonald's but I find
that in China they focus more on
delivery and they promis to get
everything delivered within 30 minutes
which they actually keep to and that's
incredibly impressive last night I
ordered the chicken carcass it took 28
minutes got a Big Mac earlier that was
10 minutes so they are very very
punctual they're also open for very long
from 7: till 10:00 p.m. and there are
many 24-hour branches so extremely
convenient now McDonald's is an American
brand so they have American Classics on
the menu hamburgers chicken sandwiches
but they they kind of assimilated and
made popular the burger culture in this
country it's hard to say cuz I feel like
the American taste is McDonald's I think
McDonald's has actually adapted pretty
well to Chinese tastes besides the
mcspicy burger and wings and the grow
chicken sandwich which have all become
bests sellers McDonald's actually uses
chicken thigh meat instead of breast
meat in all of its chicken burgers
except for the McChicken and I think
that's because Chinese people think
chicken breast is dry and they've also
got lots of time limited specials when
it comes to desserts like The Mantel
Burger which is kind of like a Chinese
bun and even cilantro Sunday McDonald's
everyone's going to McDonald's Burger
King's been going out to McDonald's
since what the 60s every Burger chain
try to get some sort of edge of
McDonald's we're fancier we're got
different varieties of stuff McDonald's
is number one here now and forever the
McDonald's logo should be on the
American flag damn it so China is
McDonald's second largest market bu
store count after the US in China there
are over 5,000 McDonald's locations but
KFC has over 9,000 they actually came
here first so it's KFC
then McDonald's then a local brand
called deos which does both Fried
Chicken and Burgers so they're really
just fighting an uphill
battle in China a Big Mac costs 25 Yen a
Big Mac in the US cost
$5.29 make it a Big Mac meal with a
medium fries and medium Coke and it's 36
un if you want to go large that's 4 unen
extra for a grand total of 40 Yen if you
make it a meal with the medium fries and
medium drink price goes up to
$929 upgrade that to a large and it's
$10.79 our Big Mac large meal costs
86% more so our Big Mac meal is cheaper
but at the same time the average daily
wage of a cabie in Beijing is about 200
unen give or take and so this would be
20% of their salary so it's still not
really something that you would eat on a
regular basis but maybe splurge on
let's talk nutrition this is that very
big mac again in the US it's 590
calories and all this stuff in China Our
Big Mac has 524 calories 26 G of fat 45
G of carbs 27 g of protein and
877 mg of sodium what if we did a CBO
starting with the medium fries this adds
320 calories to the meal and all this
stuff
while a medium fries in China contains
290 calories 13 G of total fat
35.9 G of carbs we're not sure if it
contains any sugars 4 g of protein and
252 Mig of sodium but you need some to
drink adding a medium Coke to that and
this kicks your meal up another 210
calories we'll do the same here's
everything in a medium Coke in
China 148 calories that leaves the grand
total for the China meal at
962 calories while in the us the total
ends up looking like this 1,120 calories
and all this other stuff get a load of
that sodi in though o from calorie count
to portion sizes we wanted to find out
all the differences between McDonald's
in the US and Italy this is food
Wars drinks at McDonald's in Italy come
in three sizes 250 ml
400 ml and 500 mL we're now going to
measure a 500 mL Coke to see if that's
true oh oh I think we're surpassing that
it's like just right below the 600 Mark
but almost there so quite generous
drinks in the US also come in four sizes
the extra small which is 355 ml or 12
flu o the small 474 ml or 16 flu o
the medium 621 ml or 21 flu oun and the
large
946 ml or 32 flu oun since we were the
ones that filled this up at the uh
restaurant and I don't think we got it
all full up I'm going to go ahead and
fill this what I think is reasonable I
can't do to the top cuz the cap is
recessed okay 32 surely you just right
there's the 32 line not even close it's
closer to 24 than it is 32 so fries in
Italy come in three sizes the regular
which technically the small medium and
large here in America our fries come in
four sizes the kids which comes in the
Happy Meal look at this little guy a
little guy the small the medium and the
large all the food Wars heads watching
know then the China episode our large
McDonald's fry was 175 G and then Japan
episode our large McDonald's fry was 190
G so clearly there's some difference in
grammage depending on I don't know the
McDonald's will go to the scooper who
knows so we're going to weigh our large
right now ready
fantastic now let's go 185 not a bad
scoop we got a good scooper this time
seems pretty small actually what about
Mech nuggets in ital you can get a bag
of four a box of six pieces nine pieces
and 20 pieces Claudia in the US our
McNuggets are available in these sizes
the four piece the six piece 10 piece 20
piece which you also have we go up one
more here in America our largest size
the 40 piece now if my calculations are
correct this is double your largest size
the iconic Big Mac both countries have
its but we're going to compare ours to
Italy's by weighing it 226 G for us Big
Mac and here is an Italian Big Mac or E
Big Mac as is written here and we're
going to weigh it now 209
G here are all the items on the
McDonald's Italy menu that you won't
find in the US and here are all the
McDonald's menu items from the US you
won't fine in Italy get a good look
Claudia let's start from the burger we
have a bunch of Italian burgers that you
won't get in the US the first one we got
here is a chicken Big Mac oh right just
destroyed chicken Big Mac is that being
inverted is that supposed to look like
this the cheese helps a little bit sauce
as well moving on we have a bacon Big
Mac yeah so there's two strips of bacon
but they're not quite big so
it does look like maybe it's just one
that's been cut in half we got a crispy
MEC bacon which is like cheeseburger
double PTY and some bacon again a bit on
the side it's funny actually because you
know growing up I thought that the
crispy Bon was the the iconic McDonald's
item and it's weird that it is actually
an Italian exclusive here are all the
burgers in the US that you can't get in
Italy starting down here the quarter
pounder with cheese it really is just a
cheeseburger that is a/ qu pound of
meats it's a great go-to burger meat
cheese onions pickles ketchup and
mustard and if you want more meat get
the Double Quarter Pounder correct not
the half pounder the Double Quarter
Pounder with cheese two patties more
meat more cheese and it's a fantastic
sandwich and then we've got the first
one of the my selection range which is a
range that was um designed with Joe
Bastianich he's an American like TV
personality and Chef this one is spec
and aago so yeah very traditional spec
is a type of a cured meat it's like a
smoked ham yeah it's a smoked ham from
the north of Italy it's actually very
very nice just very salty with that
smokey flavor it's one of my favorite
and then we have Asiago which is a
cheese made pretty much in the same area
there's also mayo and zucchini in
there a bit dry I think
you do taste the cold cut the spec just
brings that saltiness smokiness very
nice and the cheese also is quite good
yeah actually I don't know if you've
noticed but it is much bigger than the
others I mean we can even take like a
bacon Big Mac even though it's supposed
to have two paties it is much bigger and
then we have another my selection uh
Burger this one is called my BBQ this
one has got uh barbecue sauce yes I can
see it GAA cheese
and bacon and uh it's all topped off
with some balsamic vinegar it does still
have the same sort of fancy Patty that
we had before right and after this very
nice and fancy um Burgers we have a
glutenfree
burger oh wait why is it coming a bag
o yeah very o yeah not excited about
this just
I don't like the bread uh I'm sure you
can find better gluten-free bread there
are so many around and if you want
vegetables on your burger for some
strange reason you can get the quarter
pound of a cheese
deluxe with lettuce and tomato and
Mayo like a pocket of mayonnaise on that
one that's kind of weird H tastes great
you just want to go all in on the meat
you get a Double Quarter Pounder with
bacon look at
right it's really good I Al to say and
surprise another thing in our menu you
guys don't have the McDouble McDonald's
has a double cheeseburger which is
double the meat double the cheese but
also there's a McDouble on the menu
what's the difference you ask well
McDouble only has one slice of cheese as
you can see from here on top you got
ketchup mustard and uh pickles no cheese
but the cheese is in between here again
it times your economy but get the extra
slice of cheese guys come on I mean
we're not robots here we got to have
some pleasure in our lives and I think
you should get that extra slice of
cheese absorb the cost of it it's
perfectly fine you're doing great come
on next one is another one of those my
selection it's a chicken avocado and
bacon burger H it's got a different bun
this one ooh fancy all right yeah
avocado is there there's like cabbage
bit ex excited about that and this one
has kacho cavalo cilano cheese I don't
know we can call this you know so stalk
the cheese
stalk kacha cavalo comes from the same
family of mozzarella they're called
pasta filata cheeses and it's just
basically the way that you make cheese
uh when you split the milk into curs and
way it's made in a different way and you
could say that kacho cavalo is like a
Ned mozzarella so it's a very versatile
cheese that I think is not very well
known abroad So yeah thank you
McDonald's for making that uh a thing on
your menu so everybody can know about it
so here's the cheese that we were
talking about it's just always a shame
it's been put there with like avocado
and this cabbage next on we've got
double chicken barbecue after seeing all
these big ones they do look quite small
and then we have a chicken burger this
one is different from a Mech chicken
because it has ciss uh sa and no lece I
think this is glue it looks like there's
a type of glue that looks exactly like
that we also thought it'd be fun to
compare Happy Meals here's the US One
let's open up this box take a look
around I'm pretty sure this is Pokémon
this one comes with kid fries nuggets
which we got a six piece and our Pokémon
toy they get the six piece it's funny
like a six piece still seems kind of
like a lot for a kid Pokémon theme toys
coming at you these days what is this uh
okay so we got um Pikachu does this have
any value cuz there's like rare ones
like there's ones that have a lot of
value to them but any not the ones Inon
on right
card any
value we got
tanos yeah and of
course
sandaconda I'll go look on eBay after
this and see if these are worth anything
culturally I have no idea what this is I
don't know this is a
thing no I have no idea
who I don't I don't remember any of
those
names
uh cha charazard card is this
card
charmar okay in a Happy Meal in Italy
you can find four items obviously there
is a drink uh then there is a main
course that could be either nuggets and
hamburger and exclusive to Italy is a
chicken burger and a Mac toast which is
what we got today we're going to see
that in a moment then there is a side it
can either be fries or baby carrots and
a dessert this can be um either fresh
fruit actimel which is technically a
drink but it's a dessert here and
Parmesan here's our M
toast nice the surprise um of the day
yeah they're just doing some Hot Wheels
collaboration so let's have a look at
what is it I don't know do you think I
can find a vest spine here oh cute
little skateboard pink
one we also have one exclusive rub
option here in Italy it's a Mac WRA with
crisp chicken breast and Parmesan or
parmesano Rano it's made in
collaboration with jalo zafferano which
is um the number one recipe website in
Italy to be honest I think they could
have come up with a better
recipe maybe for the wrap the wrap does
look very sad just the actual bread
chicken looks okay Italy clearly has
plenty of exclusive chicken sandwich
options but we have a few of our own
here namely the MC Krispy and the spicy
M Krispy and a deluxe version of each
sandwich let's take a look it looks
closer to a chicken sandwich you would
find at a Chick-fil-A and then now uh
Burger King has the Chicken King I think
McDonald's did all the research that
they do to release this the mccrispy
sandwich now as you can tell it's just
pickles on here a crispier more natural
looking piece of fried chicken
and no sauce does always have no sauce
I don't like that I don't like a place
that gives you food in like assembly
requirements for the most part I just
get the sandwich the way it's supposed
to be so this put your own sauce in it
it's like no you put it on here's the
deluxe of it it yay that has mayo whoa
this to me is like yeah do this every
time this should just be the sandwich I
don't if you're like me and you want to
spice it
up
they have the spicy oh come on they were
their spicy sauce on here somewhere then
of course they got the spicy deluxe
which of course has spicy sauce all
veggies in there so yeah McDonald's
still a container in the chicken
sandwich game I feel now we're on to the
exclusive sides here in Italy the first
one that we got is cheesy fries the same
fry just with a bit more bacon we go
here yeah cheddar and bacon this this is
like I don't know a very sad Italian
take on poutin on the menu next for
sides we've got pancotti so actually
very excited about these because oo they
are uh Panero are from my hometown body
in the south of Italy the main
difference is that usually pancerote
like the traditional ones they are this
big they're like usually pretty wide
it's like a main meal panti normally
they have tomatoes and mozzarella is the
most common fing but in again where they
are from uh you can get them with ground
beef mozzarella and cooked ham these are
actually my favorite I used to go and
get them after school um you know that's
just they are the perfect
snack quite good actually feeling is
okay but I think a rear pancero when you
bite into it basically all the feelings
should almost come out you should like
pop you know like the first reaction
when you eat a Pato this is like and
then just sort of put your hand here and
just avoid a complete mess this brings
us to the next snack which is parano or
parmesan this is one of the most
counterfit cheeses in the world so in
Italy but also in Europe because of this
whole protection thing anything that's
called even parmesan not the real name
parano is in fact the real thing so at
least we're safe on that side having
said that I think um most of the
parmesan parano that you will
find around you know in Supermarket it's
like been aged for the bare minimum
which is 12 months so it is good it is
the real Fame but if you can choose just
have something that's been aged for a
bit longer I think in Italy we do eat a
lot of cheese as a snack like as it is
and I do have um definitely memories of
like me coming back from school you know
and then just in the afternoon grabbing
some cheese off the fridge and like
having a couple of slices or even more
than that um I think my mom still does
that so sorry for exposing you
Mom love it over here we got another
exclusive there are actually three
salads on the menu uh one is just a
plain salad one is a salad with um
tomatoes and then we got one with crispy
chicken breast and Parmesan we could
also select a dressing and we added
olive oil o um you could also get a tiny
bottle of balsamic vinegar or just
vinegar we actually have no exclusive
sides in the US every side option in our
menu can also be found in Italy I will
say though I love that they have a stick
of cheese as a side kind of like a
pallet cleanser I would love that I
would love to snack on cheese I love
snacking on cheese we should have more
cheese is what I'm trying to say we
could bring it back with the sauces it's
time for sauce talk Italy Edition la la
la sauce sa
talk that had to offend somebody sauce
talk we have several exclusive sauces
here in the United States including
spicy buffalo and then we have Ranch
honey mustard sweet and sour now I have
two because one is from the movie Loki
apparently and of course you just get
honey of all these I'd probably go sweet
and
sour but barbecue which they do have is
my favorite we have one exclusive sauce
in Italy which is spicy mustard sauce
yeah yeah it is a bit spicy not so much
though doesn't numb your tongue I think
actually it has a sweet aftertaste for
some reason for the early risers there
are plenty of exclusive breakfast items
at the US McDonald's and they're all
Savory now first thing I'm going to talk
about are the biscuits I'm not the
person to describe American biscuits to
the rest of the world they should have
hired a poet this is the bacon egg and
cheese biscuit but you can get a biscuit
version of any meat or cheese
combination that you want in the middle
here though Italy Claudia everyone look
at what I'm about to show you you know
what pancakes are you know what syrup is
you obviously know what breakfast
sandwiches are this right here is a
McGriddle and they replace the buns with
this these bun pancakes this is a
pancake Italy a pancake these here and
they somehow injected syrup in them so
it's not like syrup like a sauce it's
just like already syrup somehow and it
is Savory and sweet at the same time it
is so delicious it's a McGriddle it's
fantastic I love these this is a bacon
egg and cheese McGriddle but once again
you can get it in any various sausage
egg Andor cheese combination that you
want MC riddles check them out I am the
MC rdle number one fan over here and the
OG breakfast sandwich this is the Egg
McMuffin they got the big breakfast with
or without Hot Cakes I went with hot
cakes you got eggs bacon pancakes
English muffin this thing's fantastic
and if you want to just get hot cakes
and sausage you can also do that and
each order of Pancakes comes with our
hot cakes syrup I think an unsung hero
of the McDonald's breakfast menu been a
fan of this for years it is the sausage
breakfast burrito now let's be honest
Italy in case you're wondering this in
no way represents an actual burrito I
want to make that perfectly clear I
would not put this in the same category
as any sort of burrito breakfast or
otherwise but it's its own thing and I
think it is fantastic it is in a flower
tortilla scrabbled eggs sausage yes I
know Peppers
cheese and the secret
weapon is this their Mexican style salsa
again there is
nothing authentically Mexican about this
but it tastes great this was a go-to for
years I could put away about four of
these uh McDonald's also does offer
oatmeal specifically fruit and Maple
oatmeal moving on the Italian McDonald's
also sells breakfast items we've
got that's super sad we got scrambled
eggs with bacon and a muffin and bread
which what does look more like a muffin
and then we have a Mech muffin with
bacon and egg yeah Italians don't really
have Savory breakfast it's definitely um
a hobit like you just associate
breakfast with sweet items all right us
Al has their own exclusive maafe
items where' they
go the McDonald's is near our studio did
not have the maafe food
[Music]
items McDonald's in Italy has really
made an effort with the me cafe uh menu
items and there are really a lot of
items on the menu here so let's start
from the cross s we've got quite a few
on the menu I think this one here uh
because you can see a little bit of
brown this is the cocoa one with
sourdough pretty safe to eat this is the
plain one does look more like a French
St Cel nice layers in there as well some
air over here it's quite hard to tell
but there is a subtle subtle layer Jam
this is berries and cereal so the dough
it looks it's a little bit stiffer
and yeah does smell a little
bit more like cereals same amount of jam
that as in the others not not very
generous actually I think this one is
the last one that we got so it's the
costard this looks
like we have a bit more in there
obviously it's hard to tell because the
custard is is the same color as the um
as the dough has kind of turned the
dough
Yellow Nice lots of lemon in there
another pastry option that you can get
is this cream braid uh this is quite a
typical thing as well in Italy like you
do get this kind of pastries you can get
them also Savory in like different
regions of Italy let's see if they were
generous with the cream
here yeah I'll say
so I prefer this cream in Italy you can
also get uh some cakes we have
tiramisu which is yeah a traditional
Italian thing but not a breakfast item
like I wouldn't really have breakfast
with tiramisu I know you guys want to
hear the opinion of an Italian so we're
going to try this Tiramisu and see if
it's
proper yeah it's quite good actually we
do have other Cakes as well we have this
one which is Tora de Lona in Italian um
and that literally translates to
Grandma's cake in English this one has
lemon custard and pine
nuts I think it's a bit of a joke that
this is actually called Grandma's cake
just because you know every Italian
grandma that's good in the kitchen will
be able to make something like a 100
times better than this we've got a
strawberry cheesecake let's move on to
this three layer chocolate cake it's
like an absolute
Beast it's a bit too much I wouldn't
have this for breakfast like and then we
have a few more items here at the me
cafe in Italy we have a marshmallow
dut which looks like the most artificial
thing I've ever seen then we've got a
Nutella muffin it is true that Italians
love Nutella and they eat it all the
time you know again when I'm I was a
child my parents used to hide
it sad and the last item that we've got
is uh macaroons we have chocolate
macaroons raspberry macaroons and
pistachios macaroons or pistachio as we
do say
here
oh the inside is like dangerously green
they don't taste so much like pistachio
to be honest desserts McDonald's us we
have these exclusives St down here the
baked apple pie the day they stopped
frying these is the day I stopped eating
them now the pulling this with like
trying to make it look like it's a
homemade pastry it's not this this was
just spit out of an AI oven
[Music]
machine one a second no human I'm the
first human hand to touch this also
chocolate chip cookies they come in
orders of 1 three the trilogy
or a tote of 13 one good thing about the
McDonald's we went to today is the
McFlurry machine was totally working and
I got this one the M&M's McFlurry we use
the mini M&M's which are better than
regular M&M's I don't know why they just
are Sundays Sundays Sundays maybe my
favorite as a kid the caramel
sunde
M oh that's my childhood right there and
and get a fudge one as well for Italian
exclusive desserts we have uh pistachos
MEC flurry then a Bachi perugina
McFlurry Bachi perugina are very popular
uh chocolates they are made in peruja
which is in the center of Italy a town
in the center and here we have a coffee
sunde it's quite nice that I they
actually gave us the espresso so that we
can make our own a bit like an aato in a
way the other Sundays are caramel
berries another Bach perugina again and
fat which is basically the Italian
version of vanilla
nice yeah now on to the cold drink
options uh starting down here all the
soda options you get here in the US of
course we have way more than Italy
starting with Dr Pepper oh come
there so fantastic Diet Coke
no this completely unnatural looking
thing is high sea orange lava blast it's
not carbonated but it's also not juice I
can't explain it it's high
se you can also get a sweet tea and an
unsweetened iced tea at McDonald's what
I did feel like getting was this the
Frozen Fanta blue
raspberry oh God it's so sweet and so
serpy don't drink this don't give it to
children don't have it ever they also
have a Coke version frozen Coke also
don't bother lemonade though so we found
out that lemonade in America is the
least different from Lemonade in the UK
again this is not carbonated it's not
really juice it's something different I
don't know what lemonade is like in
Italy
but oh man so tart and so good on to
coffee drinks or should I say cold
coffee drinks from here to here
understand there's not a thing in Italy
which I think is hilarious this giant
glass right here is iced coffee you can
also get it caramel flavored or french
vanilla flavored I went with black the a
of Spades right
here oh man they do something with their
coffee there they do something where it
tastes like it's really roasted I mean
I'm sure it's not you also get a IC
latte but this over here is a frappe you
can get a mocha frappe or a caramel
frappe basically if you're an adult and
you want a milkshake you get a Frapp you
can also get smoothies at McDonald's we
have a mango pineapple smoothie and a
strawberry banana smoothie in Italy we
have a few exclusive drinks let's start
with the cold options we have lipon ice
tea both in lemon and Peach then we have
some fruit juices we have PE AE which is
very popular here in Italy um it's
should be very orange is a mix of orange
carrots and lemon yeah very orange and
it's named AE which is a c e after the
three vitamins that these fruits or like
vegetables I guess the carrots contains
and and then we got peach fruit juice
and here are our McDonald's hot coffee
drinks coffee right Italy all right we
get it we went a little overboard with
our coffee drinks here in America and
McDonald's of course is no different you
can get a caramel macchiato a caramel
cappuccino why are we doing so much
caramel stuff in America right ah
caramel latte you can also get it in
vanilla don't you can also get a mocha
latte we have a uh premium roast coffee
as I said before I don't know what
they're doing in McDonald's
but I like the coffee but you can also
get finally a black hot tea what is this
the
UK the hot drinks exclusive to Italy are
obviously the king of hot drinks
espresso uh then we've got a Moroccan
coffee which is not Moroccan in the
sense of it's not Moran style coffee uh
but weirdly enough and to be honest I
never really understood this it's named
after a type of Moroccan leather that
looks this color honestly it's like an
espresso with some milk and then we got
ginen coffee and barley coffee we
technically shouldn't really be cold
coffee because it contains no coffee it
has just barley and this is like an
alternative for people that cannot drink
coffee and uh they still want to have
something like a little espresso after
lunch yeah it smells very
cereally I don't know I'm not a big fun
and then we got just a standard uh latte
macato this is like the closest thing
you get to a latte that you will find
here in Italy so it's just a lot of milk
with a bit of coffee and some foam at
the
top in Italy a Big Mac will cost you €6
and10 in dollars that's about
$676 a Big Mac in the US will cost you
$629 it's a 3% price increase from Italy
to the US what if you turn that into a
combo meal in Italy a small Big Mac meal
with medium fries and a medium drink
will cost you
890 and that's
$986 does a combo meal make a difference
in the US a medium Big Mac combo meal
over here will cost you
$142 you can also save some money if you
buy in bulk here in Italy you can get a
two person Mac menu which includes two
Big Macs two large portions of fries two
large uh coca-colas six nuggets for
18 in the US we only do Big Mac combo
meals as mentioned before so in order to
get the same order in Italy You' have to
order two big Mach meals plus six
nuggets on the side it would cost around
$36 which in Italy is about 33 pricewise
I think they are definitely better value
than other fast food chains well notably
Five Guys I know that one is has a
reputation for being quite expensive but
I think the burger is like half the
price for the pancera I think that was
more than 3 years 3 years something
which honestly for like three of those
as a side it is a little bit sad but
again I grew up in the town of pancotti
and um I used to have like a full one
this size for like2 that was 15 years
ago so maybe now it would translate into
something like maybe five or six Once
Upon a Time McDonald's was the cheaper
option it was a lot of food for not a
lot of money as many people probably
pointed out on social media this food is
no longer inexpensive it's not expensive
maybe because of the competition maybe
because of inflation probably because of
corporate greed McDonald's and most fast
food I find is not a good value
anymore let's compare some items to see
what the nutrition is of McDonald's food
a sandwich that exists in both countries
and is theoretically identical is the
Big Mac in the US a Big Mac contains 590
calories 34 G of total fat 46 G of carbs
and 9 g of sugar how about an Italian
Big Mac one of those here contains 509
calories um of of these there are 26 G
of total fat 42 G of carbs of which 90 G
are sugars and then there are 920 mg of
sodium what if we made it a combo meal
starting with the fries am medium fry in
the US contains 320 calories 15 G of
total fat 43 G of carbs no sugar and 260
mg of sodium while a medium fries in
Italy contains 330 calories 16 G of
total fat 41 G of carbs of which 0.4 G
are sugars and 22 mg of sodium and let's
add the medium Coke to the mix it
contains 210 calories no fat 56 carbs 56
of those are sugar and 55 migs of sodium
that's funny there's salt in the soda
we'll do the same here here's what's
inside a medium Coke in Italy it's 168
calories 0 g of of fat 42 G of carbs 42
g of sugar so it's like all sugar and 0
g of sodium that leaves the total for
the Italian meal at this 1,07 calories
42 G of fat 125 G of carbs 51.4 G of
sugars and
1,32 mg of sodium while in the us the
total ends up looking like this
[Music]
let's talk about ingredients now
McDonald's Italy shares a lot of
information actually about its
ingredients uh that's because the
majority of the items on the menu are
made with 100% uh Italian products the
beef like the one that's used in the Big
Mac is sourced from over 15,000
different Farms are located in Northern
Italy around the regions of Lombardy uh
where we are now now in uh the capital
of which is Milan and Piedmont there are
apples from South Tio which is where
spec is made just at the border with
Austria and just to give some
recognition to the southern regions
because I'm from there uh so no bias at
all we've got some apricots from the um
vuan National Park so in Campania and
Sicilian oranges and when we talk about
dop this red label here is what you're
looking for it's a label that's used for
a lot lot of traditional products around
the EU and that means that they have to
be made with certain following certain
specific standards most of the time in a
very artisanal way but that also means
that certain products like parmeson
cannot be made outside of a specific
area that has to do with the climate so
for example for cheese the main argument
is that it's a raw milk cheese and in R
milk cheeses you do taste what the cows
eat so obviously the grass has a
different taste depending on where you
are in the world but we do have some
American sourc ingredients for
McDonald's the potatoes used for our
fries are grown in Washington at 100
circles Farm which is owned by Bill
Gates apparently they grow the potatoes
in circles so big you can see it from
space the potatoes are then cut into
fries at 70 mph which is faster than a
cheetah that's the unit of
measurement that natural secret
ingredient to McDonald's fries is beef
flavoring which they've been doing since
the 1950s want to see there's any
differences in the US and the Italy's
Big Mac these are all the ingredients in
a big Mech in the US Al together that's
68 ingredients to make up a Big Mac
that's a lot 28 of those ingredients are
in the bun which is quite a lot for
bread the Big Mac sauce also has a lot
of ingredients 26 alog together and it
seems like we added a lot of relish to
ours which bulks out the ingredients in
Italy there are 54 ingredients in a Big
Mac here they are we only have 20
ingredients in the band actually because
we don't fortify the flour like you do
in the US Our Big Mac s has 15
ingredients which is still nine less
than the uh us Big Mac Joe most of the
other ingredients are similar but we
don't have as many colorings or
thickeners as you do in the US some of
the ingredients listed in our Us big
Mech sauce caught our attention so we
want to explain what they are first up
propylene glycol elgate is derived from
brown seaweed and is a thickener used in
foods to give it smooth natural texture
next up we got hydrolized corn which is
a plant protein from corn or Maze and is
used as a flavoring for its Umami taste
sodium citrate helps cheese to melt
without becoming
greasy I did grow up uh with with
McDonald's I definitely celebrated
couple of birthdays over there I had my
uh share of like Happy Meal with like
lots of little girly toys it is
definitely considered healthier than
other fast food chains because it has
been around for quite some time but also
obviously because he has italianized a
lot over the years incorporating things
like parmesan or like traditional
cheeses and cold cuts so just appealing
a little bit more to the taste of like
Italians I have been to stores in the US
and the UK um and Italian McDonald's
I don't know a little bit fancier it's
everywhere and made burgers and fries
and sodas to go the most popular meal in
the country and then how many places
followed suit with Burger King and
Wendy's and all the like and now we got
chicken sandwich versions ones we got
fried
McDonald's McDonald's ified the entire
country and the world McDonald's is like
Nike or Christianity it's
everywhere the number one it's like the
mascot of the show okay and is it name
Pokemon yeah no Pokemon is the type like
anal
oh